[Music]
event
has been set up to adhere to social
distancing guidelines as outlined by
health experts
in the state of michigan thanks
everyone please welcome our first
speaker an essential worker at a grocery
store and a ufcw
local 876 member matt hoffman
thank you mr vice president for the
opportunity
to speak about what essential grocery
workers including countless ufcw
members like myself are dealing with my
name is matt hoffman
and i'm a grocery store worker in emily
city michigan and i have been on the
front lines of the pandemic since day
one
working around the clock to help make
sure families in my community have the
food they need
during this crisis i live in a small
town
and our community has been devastated by
cobia 19
and the damage it has done to our
economy
over these many months there is not a
day that goes by
workers like me are not putting our
lives on the line
in the beginning we had no productive
equipment and were even told
we would be sent home without pay if we
wore
mass or gloves on the job the health
risks we face are real
we interact with the public every day we
are vital to the food supply
but we cannot do our job if we are not
protected
essential workers like us deserve
essential
precautions like hazard pay
i am here today because we need to build
a better america
than one we see we need to create good
jobs
we need to make sure employers do the
right
and pay us for the risks we face
we can't afford to listen to companies
that make billions in profit
and then cut hazard pay we need a leader
who puts hard-working men and women
and their families first this is why
i'm supporting joe biden
lastly i would like to urge all my
friends and family
regardless of their party to vote for
vice
president biden so we can have a
president who prior towards
us in our jobs from everything i've
heard you say
and the way you clearly care for others
i know you are the leader we need
thank you again for listening to
michigan workers and welcome mr vice
president
hey folks good afternoon before i start
let me explain
the delay we wanted to make sure that
we're doing everything by the numbers
and so i uh got two uh two coveted tests
this morning
one in delaware and one by the former
white house doc who came up and
everything's cleared we want to make
sure everything was clear before i came
we were supposed to have an event after
this at a uh
at a headquarters but uh based on the
crowd size and an indoor
was concluded by the doc said best not
to do it
but i want to thank all of you i want to
thank matt
and matt you're dead right you were
putting yourself on the line and a lot
of other people did all across this
country
in your union and i want to thank david
way
secretary treasurer of local 951
uh for having me here today look
let's i'd like to start by acknowledging
which i'm sure all of you
do as well sending my prayers for the
health and safety of the first lady and
president of
president united states after they
tested positive for coven 19.
my wife jill and i prayed that they'll
make a quick and full recovery
this is not a matter of politics
it's a bracing reminder to all of us
that we have to take this virus
seriously it's not going away
automatically we have to do our part to
be responsible
means following the science listening to
the experts
washing our hands social distancing it
means wearing a mask in public and means
encouraging others to do so as well
it means having masking mandates
nationwide
the director of the cdc
center for disease control dr redfield
said and i quote
and he held up a mask he said these face
masks are the most important
powerful public health tool we have then
he held the mask
up again and said this face mask is more
guaranteed to protect me against covid
than a vaccine end of quote
leading scientists from the university
of washington
tell us that we can save more than one
hundred thousand american lives in the
next hundred days alone
if everyone wore a mask in public
so let me repeat that because it's
so important we can save 100
000 lives in the next 100 days according
to the head of the cdc
if everyone wears a mask in public
so be patriotic it's not about being a
tough guy
it's about doing your part wearing a
mask is not only going to protect you
but also protects those around you your
mom
your dad your brother your sister
husband wife neighbor co-worker
don't just do it for yourself do it for
the people you love
the people you work with the seriousness
of this virus
also underscores that we need regular
testing
with results turned around rapidly and
that's available to everyone
it's not just the folks in the white
house or who travel with me
that deserve regular testing is folks in
the meatpacking
and food processing plants grocery store
workers
every single american deserves safety
and peace of mind
and it means we need transparency those
who test positive
need to participate and contact tracy so
that everyone
who they may have exposed can get tested
themselves
that's how you stop transmission for any
epidemic it's basic we need to take the
science of fighting this disease
seriously if we're going to save lives
and above all the news is a reminder
that we
as a nation need to do better in dealing
with this
pandemic taking these steps
is how we'll protect ourselves and just
as important
is how we will protect one another
i hope that all those who are fighting
this virus
including the first family and so many
americans today
recover and recover soon
my prayers are with the families on the
more than 200 i think it's seven now 207
000 americans who have died from this
virus
many of them got up this morning at the
breakfast table with an empty chair
of someone they lost and they loved we
understand
and there's more than seven million
americans
who are now infected have been infected
that includes folks here in grand rapids
and all across michigan
especially all of you at the uf with
ufcw
who are on the front lines of this
pandemic and on the front lines of this
economic crisis
ufcw workers who have always been on the
front lines of fighting
for dignity and respect you deserve i
know it's been tough
this morning september jobs report came
out
the last one before election day i'm
grateful for all those who were able to
get their jobs back to work again but
there's fewer jobs than we had hoped for
millions of families millions are still
wondering
when it will be their turn to come back
from the brink
and the signs according to the national
press are not encouraging
once again the pace of job gains is
slowing down
once again we're seeing temporary
layoffs turn permanent
this month marked the largest single
month increase in long-term unemployment
since we started keeping records in
1948.
there are now an additional 781 000
americans
who've been trying to find work at least
for at least six months
they've been looking to work for at
least six months and haven't found it
and in the past that's a sign for
permanency for them
we're still down 647 000 manufacturing
jobs nationwide
since the crisis started all told
we are now 30 million workers who have
either lost ours
lost paychecks or lost their jobs
entirely
participating in the labor force
participation fell
last month and remained sharply down
since this crisis began especially for
women
there's another roughly 700 000 people
who've dropped out of the labor force
stopped looking for a job
the vast majority were women
demonstrating once again how this
economic crisis has been especially
tough
on women and families in this country
this will be the first presidency in
modern history to leave
office with fewer jobs than when it came
into office
michigan has lost more than 361 thousand
jobs
since the beginning of 2017. in fact
factories were already closing before
covert
like the knoll plan here in grand rapids
they announced back in january
they were shutting down and cutting 210
local jobs
manufacturing has already slipped in a
recession last year
the net loss of auto manufacturing jobs
you saw here in michigan and that
economic
pain was only amplified by the pandemic
your schools and local businesses are
closed like
all places around america more than 26
million unemployment claims were filed
by americans last month 46 million
americans
have exhausted their emergency savings
and essential workers here in grand
rapids won't forget
how the ufcw members saw their jobs turn
suddenly into a life and death
task folks today
today's report reinforces another
painful trend
the continuing of what economists call
a k shaped recovery
the k means that letter going up
that's those who on the top it keeps
going up
well everyone else in the middle is
going down and below
we're seeing things get worse it means
essential workers
ufcw workers who sacrifice to keep us
going
through the pandemic and continue it are
being left behind
by the most unequal recovery in modern
history
because while workers are struggling
this is a fact the top
100 billionaires in america have done
pretty well just the top 100 of them
they've made up more than 30
billion dollars this year
the last nine months and everyone else
though you get you keep hoping
you get the bottom of that k-shaped
recovery
you get the downward slide you'll have
to figure out how you're going to pay
the bills and put food in the table how
to balance
doing your job with being a teacher to
your kids because their school has gone
remote
you're asked to risk your neck because
you can't work from home
or the risks for covet are kept outside
because you work at a meatpacking plan
or an assembly line
or at a checkout counter you know
i do understand this is a scary time
non-certain time
i understand and i see you because i see
the world from where i grew up in
scranton pennsylvania
a lot like grand rapids it's filled with
awful lot of good people
busting their neck every day doing the
right thing for the families
and scrant my mom used to have an
expression she said not just in scranton
but from the time we left there
say joey nobody's better than you joey
but
everybody's your equal my dad's
constantly refrained after he lost a job
in scranton when there were no more work
and he had to move to delaware he moved
away for a little over a year come back
every weekend to see us
by the time we finally a couple years
down the road in delaware gotta finally
be able to buy a home
my dad used to use this expression he
said joey a job's about a lot more than
a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community
these are the values that shaped
my growing up and i suspect most of you
they shaped my whole life so i know and
understood from the very beginning of
consciousness about this
that wall street and ceos didn't build
this country
the middle class built this country and
unions built the middle class
that's why i've laid out a comprehensive
agenda not just to rebuild our
communities
but to make bold investments so we can
build back
and build back better an independent
analysis actually from wall street
moody's projected that my plan will
create
18.6 million jobs
7 million more than the administration's
economic plan
and 1 trillion more in economic growth
than the president's plan that's not
coming from a liberal think tank
that's coming from moody's here's how my
plan works
i'm going to raise taxes on people only
making over 400 anyone making less than
400 000
a year won't pay a penny more but i'm
going to ask the very big corporations
the fortune 500 and the wealthy
to pay their fair share for a change
that means raising the corporate tax
rate which was in the mid 30s
and now is 21 back to 28
that means making sure that no big
company gets away with paying
zero taxes as 91
fortune 500 companies do today making
billions of dollars
zero taxes how many you pay zero taxes
it means making sure the wealthiest
americans
don't get to pay at a lower tax rate
because they're making money on their
investments
but they pay at the same rate that they
pay for their salary
these changes in the tax code will raise
the money
they'll allow me to invest in working
people and growing the middle class
which when i announced i was running i
said that's the reason
to rebuild the backbone of this country
hard-working folks in the middle class
we're going to invest in creating
millions of good paying jobs union jobs
and this is by the way this my plan has
been thoroughly analyzed
by a whole bunch of folks take
infrastructure
building roads bridges highways ports
airports
will put millions of people to work in
good paying union jobs
and create the foundation for growth in
this country
clean energy just upgrading four million
buildings and weatherizing two million
homes will create at least
one million good paying jobs
leading the world on electric vehicles
and building
500 000 electric vehicle charging
stations on our highways
will create 1 million new auto jobs
here in this state the manufacturing and
technology in those areas making sure
making sure the future is made in
america
made in michigan with good union jobs
you know the federal government spends
600 billion dollars a year your tax
dollars
600 billion a year to purchase
everything
from military equipment to steel to cars
to trucks to federal fleets
at 600 million billion dollars well i'm
president
we're going to make sure we finally make
good on a commitment made a long time
ago
that these products all these contracts
that the president united states and the
federal government can award
make sure those products are made by
americans
in america making sure
that that's done it's estimated that
will create
5 million new manufacturing jobs
and technology jobs for small businesses
we're going to make sure small
businesses come out of the out on the
other side
of this terrible circumstance
with access to capital and the ability
to deal with the debts that have been
accumulated during this
pandemic and we'll make investments to
increase incomes as well
15 minimum wage no one no one should be
in a position
to have to work two jobs just to get
above the poverty line
we're going to bring jack brack jobs
from america from overseas to america
direct billions of dollars in
revitalization funds and competitive
grants to help
communities like those in western
michigan compete for new business
startups
for our central workers we're not just
going to praise you
we're going to pay you a good wage to
ensure you have a strong benefits
we're going to ease the burden of the
major costs in your life health care
we'll build on the affordable care act
through a new health insurance option
a not-for-profit public option which
will give private insurers
a real competitor we'll increase
subsidies
for your premiums that are so they're
lower so you can afford
the plans with lower deductions and
lower out-of-pocket expenses
it will cost that plan alone will cost
over
700 billion over 10 years but it's paid
for
by eliminating those tax cuts
for a 40 year old making 50 000 a year
your monthly premium will go down by a
third
will take on the pharmaceutical
companies with a plan that slashes the
cost of
prescription drugs for up to 60 percent
medicare will be able to negotiate
prices for drugs
fundamentally lowering those prices and
child
care a lot of you are dealing with that
now how do you go to work if you have
work
and take care of your kids or
an aging relative that's in trouble
we're going to make high quality child
care affordable and accessible
every three and four-year-old will have
access to free
quality preschool we're going to make
sure that low and middle income families
will never have to pay more than
seven percent of their income for
caring for a young child an education
beyond high
school we're going to make sure that
four-year
college tuitions of a state university
is tuition free
for any family making less than 125 000
community college will be free
and programs will be free as well if
you're buying your first home
you'll have a fifteen thousand dollar
help
to get there these are all things that
people have been talking about for a
while we're going to protect social
security
increases for millions of seniors the
president's talking about
giving uh eliminating the withholding
tax
well that's wonderful except for one
thing the actuary of social security
said if that plan goes through social
security bankrupt
by 2023 folks
i promise you we can do this
let me close by saying this
i know i know a lot of people around
here
are tired of feeling overlooked and
disrespected
i get that the people i met this week
taking a train through northeastern ohio
and western pennsylvania
people like the dedicated elementary
school teacher from lordstown ohio
whose husband when lordstown shut down
accepted a transfer kentucky eight hours
away
each direction in order to be able to
keep his health care and his pension
after the gm plant closed
folks who worry about health care will
the affordable care act still be there
for them
why why they ask will i be among the 100
million americans
who could lose the protections for
pre-existing conditions
like asthma and diabetes where once
again women will be able to charge
the higher premium just simply because
they're a woman
where insurers no longer have to allow
you to be able to keep your kids on a
health care plan unless 26.
what will happen to your medicare
benefits
your social security will they still be
there when you retire
i'm asked many times in recent years how
do we get to the place where people
who stock our shelves pack our food
teach our kids like my family take care
of my wife take care of
our sick who race in the burning
buildings and pick up the garbage off
our streets
who did how do we get to the place
where you all don't think we see you
anymore or hear them
and most importantly respect them that
has to change
i know it can i come from those
neighborhoods
we can get this pandemic under control
so we can get our economy working again
for everyone
but this cannot be a partisan moment
it must be an american moment we have to
come together as a nation
i'm running as a democrat but i
am overrun and governed as an american
president
whether you voted for me or against me i
will represent you
and those who see each other as fellow
americans who just don't live in
red states or blue states but who live
in and love the united states of america
that's who we are and there's never been
a single
solitary thing america's been unable to
do think of this
not once not a single thing we've not
been able to overcome
when we've done it together so let's get
the heck up
remember who in god's name we are this
is the united states of america
there's nothing beyond our capacity i
want to say god bless you
may god protect the first family and
every family is dealing with this virus
and may god protect our troops
thank you thank you thank you
foreign